This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In the famous children's fairy tale, the ugly duckling, a mother duck lays a clutch of eggs. When the hatchlings emerge, one is different from the rest. He is huge and awkward looking. His feathers are not yellow or black, but a muted gray. As soon as he's hatched, the bullying begins, not only from his siblings, but other animals too. And so the ugly duckling roams the countryside, slowly accepting his fate of being an outcast.
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在著名的童话故事《丑小鸭》中，鸭妈妈孵了一窝蛋。当小鸭子破壳而出时，其中一只与众不同。他体型巨大，看起来笨手笨脚。他的羽毛不是黄色或黑色的，而是暗淡的灰色。他一出生，欺凌就开始了，不仅来自他的兄弟姐妹，还有其他动物。于是，丑小鸭在乡间流浪，慢慢接受了他作为被遗弃者的命运。
Then one day, he sees a flock of swans, and, transged by their beauty, he swims toward them. As he gets closer, he expects them to be disgusted by his appearance, just like all the other creatures he has encountered. But to his surprise, they welcome him with open wings. You know the rest of the story. The flock of swans sees the duckling for what he truly is, a young swan who will grow up to be as beautiful as the rest of them. I've long had misgivings about the story. What is its moral? If people don't look like they belong to our tribe, it's okay to treat them badly.
有一天，他看到一群天鹅，被它们的美丽所震撼，于是向它们游去。当他靠近时，他以为它们会像他遇到的所有其他生物一样，对他的外表感到厌恶。但令他惊讶的是，它们张开翅膀欢迎他。你知道故事的结局。天鹅群看到了小鸭子的真面目，他是一只年轻的天鹅，长大后会像它们一样美丽。我长期以来对这个故事一直有疑虑。它的寓意是什么？如果人们看起来不属于我们的部落，就可以随意对待他们吗？
We can only find acceptance among people who are just like us. To be ugly is to be cursed. In our episode last week, we explored the science of beauty, why we are attracted to it, and how we are moved by it. If you missed that episode, please do listen to it. This week, we explore some of the more complicated elements of our fascination with beauty, especially beautiful people. From infancy, human beings are fascinated by those who are good looking. The other stars of our movies and magazines, objects of our adoration. But our unthinking adulation of beauty can come with
我们只能在与我们相似的人群中找到认同感。长得丑就是一种诅咒。在上周的节目中，我们探讨了美的科学，为什么我们会被美吸引，以及我们如何被它所打动。如果你错过了那一集，请务必去听听。本周，我们将探讨我们对美，尤其是对美貌之人的迷恋中一些更复杂的因素。从婴儿时期起，人类就对长相好看的人着迷。他们是我们电影和杂志的明星，是我们崇拜的对象。但我们对美貌不假思索的吹捧可能会带来
steep costs. The science of beauty bias this week on Hidden Brain. From a very young age, we are taught to see past people's looks. We tell children, don't judge a book by its cover. Beauty is only skin deep. It's what's on the inside that counts. Growing up, Vivian Ziaz heard these aphorisms many times. But when she was in graduate school, she found herself drawing a quick and unkind impression about a young student. My advisor came and he said, I have an undergraduate who wants to work in the lab and she would be great as a research assistant for you. And so he introduces me to this student and she was really disheveled like her hair wasn't like combed well and she wasn't well put together.
沉重的代价。本周《Hidden Brain》探讨美的偏见。从很小的时候起，我们就被教导要透过外表看人。我们告诉孩子，不要以貌取人。美貌只是肤浅的。内在美才是最重要的。在成长过程中，薇薇安·扎伊亚斯多次听到这些格言。但在读研究生时，她发现自己对一名年轻学生产生了快速且不友好的印象。我的导师过来对我说，我有一个本科生想在实验室工作，她非常适合做你的研究助理。于是他把我介绍给这个学生，她看起来真的很邋遢，比如她的头发没梳好，整个人看起来很不修边幅。
Her appearance looked a little messy, and I was like, oh, oh. Vivian Falfschi was in a high-stake setting. She didn't want anyone on her team who wasn't top notch. Would this undergraduate be able to cut it? I mean, I can, I see it in my mind's eye. They're standing there by the doorway into the lab. And he just, you know, brings her and introduces her to me for the first time. And I wasn't happy. But we worked together a lot, we worked
她的外表看起来有点乱，我当时想，哦，天哪。薇薇安·法尔斯基当时处于一个高风险的环境中。她不希望团队里有不是顶尖的人。这个本科生能胜任吗？我的意思是，我能，我脑海里能浮现出那个画面。他们站在实验室门口。他只是，你知道，带她过来，第一次把她介绍给我。我当时很不高兴。但我们一起工作了很多，我们
together over the course of a year. And she was socially warm and engaged. She was very orderly and dutiful. So she, you so she was able to meet all the requirements very quickly and did it well. It turned out that she was one of the best research assistants I ended up having. She was excellent. My impression was so wrong that has stayed with me all these years. Did you ever apologize to her for your initial impressions of her? I don't know if she registered it.
在这一年里一起工作。她社交热情且积极。她非常守规矩且尽责。所以她，你懂的，她很快就达到了所有要求，并且做得很好。事实证明，她是我最终拥有的最好的研究助理之一。她非常出色。我的印象错得离谱，这多年来一直萦绕在我心头。你有没有因为最初对她的印象而向她道歉？我不知道她是否察觉到了。
I think I was still polite. I was definitely not rude. And I think I might have a judgment that is registered internally. And I don't know how much she picked up on that. I would be doing a lot of apologizing. Every time I got me to judgment I was wrong, I had to apologize. Part of the reason the story has stayed with Vivian is that she went on to become a psychologist who studies the very mistake she made with a young undergrad. Vivian, who now works at Cornell University, would come to study the so-called beauty bias. She says this bias
我想我当时还是很有礼貌的。我绝对没有粗鲁。而且我想我可能在内心产生了一种判断。我不知道她察觉到了多少。如果我每次判断错误都要道歉，那我得道多少歉啊。这个故事一直留在薇薇安脑海中的部分原因是，她后来成为了一名心理学家，专门研究她对那位年轻本科生所犯的错误。现在在康奈尔大学工作的薇薇安，开始研究所谓的“美貌偏见”。她说这种偏见
involves leaping to a number of unsupported conclusions. What is beautiful is good and what is beautiful is also intelligent and popular and strong and competent and happy. And so we usually, when we judge someone as beautiful, we go way beyond the judgment of their physical appearance to making inferences about what they are like in a whole number of other domains. And so we think they have a lot of friends and they're really good parents and they're a wonderful partner and they must have such fun when they go on vacation. So we really overgeneralize way beyond what we should, based on the
涉及跳跃到许多未经证实的结论。美即是好，美的人也更聪明、更受欢迎、更强大、更有能力、更快乐。因此，当我们判断某人很美时，我们通常会超越对他们外表的判断，推断他们在其他许多领域的情况。所以我们认为他们有很多朋友，他们是很好的父母，他们是出色的伴侣，他们去度假时一定玩得很开心。所以我们确实过度概括了，远远超出了我们应该做的，基于
information that we're bleeding from just physical appearance. Vivian remembers another time. She drew a quick inference about someone based on looks. We have speakers give various academic talks and often now to advertise the talk you see the person's photograph. So their photograph is presented along with the title of their talk. And I remember seeing,
我们仅仅从外表获得的信息。薇薇安记得另一次。她根据外表对某人做出了快速推断。我们有演讲者进行各种学术讲座，现在为了宣传讲座，通常会看到那个人的照片。所以他们的照片会和讲座标题一起展示。我记得看到，
there was a speaker coming in and seeing this person's photograph. And I didn't think it was a very good photograph. But I remember I had a very strong reaction to the photograph, which is kind of rare because often they're very standard pictures that people have of themselves. The person comes and gives a talk. And actually that photograph was so strong, it listed such a strong reaction to me. It was so almost to the point where I was like, how could this person give a good talk? It was such a strong reaction. The person comes to visit,
有一位演讲者要来，看到了这个人的照片。我觉得那张照片拍得不太好。但我记得我对那张照片有非常强烈的反应，这很罕见，因为通常人们的照片都很标准。那个人来了并做了演讲。实际上那张照片太强烈了，引起了我如此强烈的反应。几乎到了我心想，这个人怎么能做出好的演讲？反应太强烈了。那个人来访，
they give a talk, and they're the loveliest person. They are so authentic and engaging, and that initial impression was erased. And I think it really said a lot about the person and their talk and their energy during the talk that was able to kind of undo that initial impression. Hmm. And of course, what usually would happen is that we might look at a photograph,
他们做了演讲，他们是最可爱的人。他们非常真诚且引人入胜，最初的印象被抹去了。我认为这确实说明了那个人的很多情况，他们的演讲以及他们在演讲期间的能量，能够消除那种最初的印象。嗯。当然，通常会发生的情况是，我们可能会看一张照片，
reach an unconscious conclusion about that person and never attend that talk and never have that impression corrected. Yeah, absolutely. I think also sometimes it is harder to correct for it. I think in the case of the research assistant and the case of the speaker giving their talk, they provided clear and diagnostic information that my initial impression was wrong. And sometimes when we meet someone, they might not be able to provide that clear information that the impression is wrong. You know, some interactions are
对那个人得出一个无意识的结论，然后永远不去听那个讲座，也永远无法纠正那个印象。是的，绝对是这样。我也认为有时更难纠正它。我认为在研究助理和演讲者的案例中，他们提供了清晰且具有诊断性的信息，证明我最初的印象是错误的。有时当我们遇到某人时，他们可能无法提供那种清晰的信息来证明印象是错误的。你知道，有些互动是
pretty mundane and you engage in small talk. Perhaps in those conversations, there wouldn't be enough disconfirming information to undo that initial impression. In fact, the swift conclusions we draw about people based on how they look can often be confirmed by our perceptions of how they act. We are often on the lookout for evidence in the way people behave that will back up our initial impressions. Like heat-seeking missiles, we zero in on any clues that suggest that our biases are not biases, but facts. Vivian remembers the time she saw the movie, no country for all men. It's based on the great novel by Carmack McCarthy, and it features a psychopathic killer
相当平凡的，你只是进行闲聊。也许在那些对话中，没有足够的反证信息来消除那种最初的印象。事实上，我们根据人们的外表对他们做出的迅速结论，往往会被我们对他们行为的感知所证实。我们经常在人们的行为中寻找证据，以支持我们最初的印象。就像热寻导弹一样，我们锁定任何暗示我们的偏见不是偏见而是事实的线索。薇薇安记得她看电影《老无所依》的时候。它改编自科马克·麦卡锡的伟大小说，其中有一个精神病杀手
named Anton Shiger. Yeah, one thing that stuck with me was his bow cut, right? His haircut was just cut straight across, straight down, and I think the way that framed his face was just he looked like a psychopath. And so part of me thought that the way he looked was the way the actor looked. And so to me, I was like, well, that must be an easy role since the actor looks like that. It's easy for him to play a psychopath.
名叫安东·奇古尔。是的，有一件事让我印象深刻，就是他的波波头，对吧？他的发型就是直接剪平，直直地垂下来，我认为那种勾勒他脸部轮廓的方式让他看起来就像个精神病患者。所以我的一部分想法是，他的长相就是演员本人的长相。所以对我来说，我想，好吧，那一定是个容易的角色，因为演员看起来就是那样。他演精神病患者很容易。
Sometime later, Vivian was watching the Oscars. The actor who played Anton Shiger was up for an award, and Vivian realized she had pictured him all wrong. The way he presented himself in that movie was drastically different than the way he typically presents himself. And at the Oscars, like Javier Bardem, you know, is a very attractive man, right? And very handsome, warm, you know, he transformed himself physically for that role. And it's really interesting because sometimes you think, I mean, that's the same person. The person in the movie would not be someone that you would judge as attractive, right? Not attractive, he's unattractive.
后来，薇薇安在看奥斯卡颁奖典礼。饰演安东·奇古尔的演员获得了提名，薇薇安意识到她完全想错了。他在那部电影中的表现方式与他平时的表现方式截然不同。在奥斯卡颁奖典礼上，哈维尔·巴登，你知道，是一个非常有吸引力的男人，对吧？非常英俊，温暖，你知道，他为了那个角色在身体上改变了自己。这真的很有趣，因为有时你会想，我的意思是，那是同一个人。电影里的人不会是你认为有吸引力的人，对吧？没有吸引力，他很丑。
And yet he, as an actor, is extremely attractive. I mean, really what this shows is that he was actually acting. Right. He wasn't just playing himself. He was actually acting. And when I first saw it, I was like, that's the way he looks, but it was part of how he acted that,
然而他作为一名演员，非常有吸引力。我的意思是，这真正表明的是他确实在演戏。对。他不仅仅是在扮演自己。他确实在演戏。当我第一次看到它时，我想，那就是他的长相，但那是他表演的一部分，
you know, gave off this impression of who he was. I asked Vivian why we draw set sweeping conclusions from the faces we see. I think that as social beings, we wanna make sense of this world that we're in, and the social world is highly complex, and so we want to make sense of this world that we're in. And the social world is highly complex. And so we want to make a prediction of who is it that we're interacting with. And so we use these cues that we see to make predictions.
你知道，给人留下了他是谁的印象。我问薇薇安为什么我们从看到的脸孔中得出如此笼统的结论。我认为作为社会性生物，我们想要理解我们所处的这个世界，而社会世界是非常复杂的，所以我们想要理解我们所处的这个世界。社会世界是非常复杂的。所以我们想要对我们正在互动的人做出预测。因此，我们利用看到的这些线索来做出预测。
And it kind of simplifies the world for us. Most of us know that discriminating against people on the basis of race, or gender, or sexual orientation is wrong. But it's harder to be outraged by the beauty bias, even though it can have pernicious effects in the world. That's because when we stare adoringly at movie stars and music icons, this bias doesn't feel like a negative thing. It feels positive, even joyous. When we come back, how appearances influence our interactions with others, affect our relationships,
这在某种程度上简化了世界。我们大多数人都知道，基于种族、性别或性取向歧视他人是错误的。但要对“美貌偏见”感到愤怒则更难，尽管它在世界上可能会产生有害的影响。这是因为当我们深情地凝视电影明星和音乐偶像时，这种偏见并不觉得是一件负面的事情。它感觉是积极的，甚至是快乐的。当我们回来时，外表如何影响我们与他人的互动，影响我们的关系，
and shape the most important decisions in our lives. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. On TV, celebrities hawk everything from shoes and soda to clothes and car insurance. Why is this? Why do we care if Tiger Woods wears Nike apparel? Or if Patrick Mahomes uses state farm insurance? Well, the answer is obvious. If we like the celebrities, advertisers are hoping that some of our affection for these stars will rub off on their products.
并塑造我们生活中最重要的决定。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在电视上，名人们兜售从鞋子、汽水到衣服和汽车保险的所有东西。这是为什么？为什么我们关心泰格·伍兹是否穿耐克服装？或者帕特里克·马霍姆斯是否使用State Farm保险？嗯，答案显而易见。如果我们喜欢这些名人，广告商希望我们对这些明星的一些喜爱能转移到他们的产品上。
At Cornell University, psychologist Vivian Zeya has studied why we draw quick conclusions about others based on how they look and the effects this has on our lives. She says the beauty bias is part of a larger phenomenon in psychology known as the halo effect. The halo effect is that when we judge someone to be attractive, we go beyond their physical appearance and make a whole bunch of other inferences that they're good at work and have lots of friends and they're funny and social and make a lot of money. And so the halo effect is just that we go way beyond the judgment of attractiveness and make an inference that that person is good at a whole number of other things and has a number of positive
在康奈尔大学，心理学家薇薇安·扎亚研究了为什么我们根据人们的外表对他人做出快速结论，以及这对我们的生活有什么影响。她说美貌偏见是心理学中一个更大现象的一部分，被称为“光环效应”。光环效应是指当我们判断某人有吸引力时，我们会超越他们的外表，做出许多其他推断，认为他们工作出色、有很多朋友、风趣、善于社交且赚很多钱。所以光环效应就是我们远远超出了对吸引力的判断，推断那个人在许多其他方面都很优秀，并拥有许多积极的
attributes. So some years ago Vivian you brought people into the lab and you showed them photographs and these photographs resemble someone they knew. Tell me about this study and what you found. So in this study, we brought in couples, heterosexual couples, that had been in a relationship for about six months, and we took their photographs. They then came back into the lab, and we told them that they were going to do a task where we were going to show them photographs of strangers and that they were going to do a task where we were going to show
属性。所以几年前，薇薇安，你把人们带进实验室，给他们看了照片，这些照片看起来像他们认识的人。告诉我关于这项研究以及你的发现。所以在这项研究中，我们带进了一些情侣，异性恋情侣，他们已经交往了大约六个月，我们拍了他们的照片。他们随后回到实验室，我们告诉他们，他们将要完成一项任务，我们将向他们展示陌生人的照片，他们将要完成一项任务，我们将向他们展示
them photographs of strangers and that they were just going to make their snap judgment. They were going to assess whether they thought the person was trustworthy or not, attractive or not, intelligent or not, competent or not. But what they didn't know is that we had taken the photographs of their partner and we had morphed them with the photographs of another participants partner. People thought they were simply rating pictures of random strangers. What they didn't know is that half of those pictures had been altered. Vivian and her team morphed photographs of strangers with photographs of people's
陌生人的照片，他们只是要做出快速判断。他们要评估他们认为那个人是否值得信赖，是否有吸引力，是否聪明，是否有能力。但他们不知道的是，我们已经拍了他们伴侣的照片，并将它们与另一位参与者伴侣的照片进行了合成。人们以为他们只是在评价随机陌生人的照片。他们不知道的是，其中一半的照片被修改过了。薇薇安和她的团队将陌生人的照片与人们
own romantic partners. In other words, a volunteer may have thought she was looking at the face of a stranger, but the face she saw subtly resembled her boyfriend. And what we found was that women in particular were more likely to judge a stranger who bore resemblance to their partner more favorably, as more trustworthy, as more intelligent, more attractive, less aggressive, men only showed a preference for the judgment of attractive. They ended up judging strangers that resemble
自己的浪漫伴侣的照片进行了合成。换句话说，一名志愿者可能以为她正在看一个陌生人的脸，但她看到的脸微妙地像她的男朋友。我们发现，女性尤其更有可能对长得像她们伴侣的陌生人做出更有利的评价，认为他们更值得信赖、更聪明、更有吸引力、攻击性更低；男性只表现出对吸引力判断的偏好。他们最终评价长得像
their partner as more attractive. But for the other traits, there was no significant difference. It was a simple test of the idea that we have quick and automatic associations with the faces we see. In this case, by having a photograph resemble a volunteer's boyfriend, the volunteer associated the warm feelings she had for her partner with the stranger. So in this study, we were interested in what's called transference. And I know transference is a psychodynamic term, Freudian term, where the patient is, you
他们伴侣的陌生人更有吸引力。但对于其他特质，没有显著差异。这是一个关于我们对所见脸孔有快速且自动联想这一观点的简单测试。在这种情况下，通过让照片看起来像志愿者的男朋友，志愿者将她对伴侣的温暖感觉与陌生人联系了起来。所以在这项研究中，我们对所谓的“移情”感兴趣。我知道移情是一个心理动力学术语，弗洛伊德术语，即病人正在，你
know, having a therapy session and then starts transferring their feelings from an existing relationship onto the therapist. And that was deemed as an important milestone because then in therapy, they can kind of work out some of these dynamics that the patient is experiencing in their existing relationships. But there's social cognitive perspective.
知道，进行治疗，然后开始将他们对现有关系的感受转移到治疗师身上。这被认为是一个重要的里程碑，因为在治疗中，他们可以解决病人现有关系中经历的一些动态。但从社会认知角度来看，
We can study transference where if you meet someone and they bear some resemblance to someone that you already know, it's going to basically activate the representation, the memory you have of the person that you know. You might not be aware that's being activated. You can activate that memory implicitly. You're not necessarily consciously aware. And you activate the memory of the person you already know. And you basically transfer that memory onto this new person. And you think the new person has all the characteristics of the person that you already know.
我们可以研究移情，如果你遇到某人，而他们与你认识的人有某种相似之处，它基本上会激活你对你认识的人的表征和记忆。你可能没有意识到它正在被激活。你可以隐性地激活那个记忆。你不一定有意识地意识到。你激活了你已经认识的人的记忆。你基本上把那个记忆转移到了这个新的人身上。你认为这个新的人拥有你已经认识的人的所有特征。
You're going way beyond the information that you have, and you think that the person is their attractive, their trustworthy, their competent, their intelligent, their less aggressive. Vivid emphasizes that so much of this happens outside of our awareness. The volunteers in the study had no idea why they suddenly felt warmly toward one stranger and cold toward another. At the end of the study, we asked them, what did you think the study was about? So we were looking to see, are they saying, well, you showed me photos of my partner? Right. And people didn't say that. Then we asked them, did anyone seem familiar? And we basically
你远远超出了你拥有的信息，你认为那个人很有吸引力、值得信赖、有能力、聪明、攻击性更低。薇薇安强调，这一切很大程度上发生在我们的意识之外。研究中的志愿者根本不知道为什么他们突然对一个陌生人感到温暖，而对另一个感到冷淡。在研究结束时，我们问他们，你认为这项研究是关于什么的？所以我们想看看，他们是否会说，嗯，你给我看了我伴侣的照片？对。人们没有那样说。然后我们问他们，有人看起来面熟吗？我们基本上
were probing to see where they are. Where a small fraction expressed some, once we, you know, said, did this, did any of the people look like your partner? A small fraction did report sub-eng knowledgement, but even when we removed them and we only looked at people who didn't report any awareness, we still found these effects. I think the mechanisms why this occurs or how this occurs is that when you meet someone, you know, we're trying to make a prediction of what they're like and we have this huge database in memory of all past experiences. And so when this person has some features that map on to features of people that we already know, it activates that memory.
是在探测看看他们是否知道。只有一小部分人表达了一些，一旦我们，你知道，说，这些人中有谁看起来像你的伴侣吗？一小部分人确实报告了某种认知，但即使我们排除了他们，只看那些没有报告任何意识的人，我们仍然发现了这些影响。我认为发生这种情况的机制是，当你遇到某人时，你知道，我们试图预测他们是什么样的人，我们在记忆中有一个巨大的过去所有经历的数据库。所以当这个人有一些特征映射到我们已经认识的人的特征时，它就会激活那个记忆。
And so then we fill in the blanks. We're not even aware that the memory of our partners activated, but now we start filling in the blanks. And we say, I like this person. I'm attracted to this person. And then we go beyond that judgment and say, I think this person is a trustworthy person and they're intelligent and they're competent.
然后我们就填补空白。我们甚至没有意识到我们伴侣的记忆被激活了，但现在我们开始填补空白。我们说，我喜欢这个人。我被这个人吸引。然后我们超越那个判断，说，我认为这个人是一个值得信赖的人，他们很聪明，他们有能力。
And they're safe, they're not going to be aggressive. Notice how much information we can draw from just a face. This of course is exactly what Vivian did when she saw the undergraduate student with the uncombed hair or the speaker who she thought didn't look very competent. Now, you could see that we are careless about the judgments we make about other people because it doesn't hurt us to draw quick conclusions about them. Most of the time, we draw conclusions about people and move on with our lives. Our judgments might hurt other people, but they don't always hurt us. Vivian wanted to test whether people became more accurate in their judgments when they
他们很安全，他们不会有攻击性。注意我们仅仅从一张脸就能提取多少信息。这当然正是薇薇安看到那个头发没梳的本科生，或者她认为看起来不太有能力的演讲者时所做的事情。现在，你可以看出我们对他人做出的判断是多么粗心，因为对他们做出快速结论并不会伤害我们。大多数时候，我们对人们做出结论，然后继续我们的生活。我们的判断可能会伤害别人，但并不总是伤害我们自己。薇薇安想测试当人们
themselves had something on the line. Yes, so in this study, we present participants with four financial partners side by side and with a portrait of what they look like. Every time they select a partner, they learn whether they got money, or they lost money. And they're supposed to figure out who's the best financial advisor. Sometimes attractive financial partners helped volunteers make money. But sometimes it was the unattractive financial partner who was the wiser choice. The question was, over time, would people learn to ignore attractiveness as a cue and focus only on the quality of the financial information?
自己有利益相关时，他们的判断是否会变得更准确。是的，所以在这项研究中，我们向参与者并排展示了四位财务合作伙伴，以及他们长相的肖像。每次他们选择一个合作伙伴，他们就会知道他们是赚了钱，还是赔了钱。他们应该找出谁是最好的财务顾问。有时有吸引力的财务合作伙伴帮助志愿者赚了钱。但有时是不那么有吸引力的财务合作伙伴做出了更明智的选择。问题是，随着时间的推移，人们是否会学会忽略吸引力作为线索，而只关注财务信息的质量？
So the way that we structure the paradigm was really to allow people to compare apples to apples. How much money are you earning? How much money are these financial consultants able to confer to you? And would we see this halo effect, this beauty is good bias, even when it comes to the money that people are earning? And presumably in this situation here, the thing that you should care about is how much money you're earning, because that's what you're looking to get out of the enterprise. It's not so much whether your partner is good looking or not. That should not matter one with.
所以我们构建范式的方式确实是为了让人们进行同类比较。你赚了多少钱？这些财务顾问能为你带来多少钱？即使在人们赚钱的情况下，我们是否也会看到这种光环效应，这种“美即是好”的偏见？据推测，在这种情况下，你应该关心的是你赚了多少钱，因为那是你想要从这个企业中得到的。这与你的合作伙伴是否好看关系不大。那根本不应该有任何影响。
Not one, but it's completely irrelevant, right? You just want to make as much money as possible. So who did the volunteers tend to pick? The financial partners who gave them steady gains over time, or the financial partners who were attractive. What we found was that even though facial attractiveness is sort of irrelevant to what participants were doing in this task, they were highly swayed by the facial attractiveness of the financial partner. They selected the attractive financial partners much more often than the unattractive. Participants would get feedback and when there was a loss, so the financial advisor
一点也不，这完全无关紧要，对吧？你只是想尽可能多赚钱。那么志愿者倾向于选择谁呢？是那些随着时间推移给他们带来稳定收益的财务合作伙伴，还是那些有吸引力的财务合作伙伴？我们发现，尽管面部吸引力在参与者执行的任务中是无关紧要的，但他们深受财务合作伙伴面部吸引力的影响。他们选择有吸引力的财务合作伙伴的频率远高于没有吸引力的。参与者会得到反馈，当出现损失时，即财务顾问
conferred a loss, financial loss, participants would return more quickly to the attractive partner than to the unattractive partner. Wait, you're saying that when they lost money, they still wouldn't learn, they still kept going back to the attractive partner? They might sample someone else for a moment and then go back to the attractive partner. And they were quicker to choose them again in the future. They were quicker to sort of forgive the attractive person another shot.
导致了损失，财务损失，参与者会比回到没有吸引力的合作伙伴更快地回到有吸引力的合作伙伴身边。等等，你是说当他们赔钱时，他们仍然不吸取教训，仍然不断回到有吸引力的合作伙伴身边？他们可能会暂时尝试其他人，然后又回到有吸引力的合作伙伴身边。而且他们在未来再次选择他们时速度更快。他们更容易原谅有吸引力的人，给他们另一次机会。
And then at the end of the study, participants were asked, who do you think was the most helpful in helping you earn money? And participants strongly thought that the attractive financial partner was most helpful in helping them earn more money. Wow. Even when that was not the case. Even when that was not the case.
然后在研究结束时，参与者被问到，你认为谁在帮助你赚钱方面最有帮助？参与者强烈认为有吸引力的财务合作伙伴在帮助他们赚更多钱方面最有帮助。哇。即使事实并非如此。即使事实并非如此。
It's kind of remarkable, isn't it, Vivian? Yes. Because in some ways, you're giving people every incentive to learn that attractiveness, in fact, is not only irrelevant, but in fact, potentially counterproductive to what their goals are and yet people effectively refuse to learn. Yes. And even though they learned which partners were more advantageous, they still preferred the attractive partner over the unattractive partner. I mean, this is a study in the lab, so obviously you're not sort of actually stealing people's
这很了不起，不是吗，薇薇安？是的。因为在某种程度上，你给了人们所有的激励去学习，事实上，吸引力不仅无关紧要，而且实际上可能对他们的目标适得其反，然而人们实际上拒绝学习。是的。即使他们了解哪些合作伙伴更有利，他们仍然更喜欢有吸引力的合作伙伴，而不是没有吸引力的合作伙伴。我的意思是，这是一项实验室研究，所以显然你并没有真正偷走人们的
money here. But you can see how this can have effects and impacts in the lab, so obviously you're not actually stealing people's money here, but you can see how this can have effects and impacts in the real world that could be quite profound. Yeah, I mean, it really says a lot about how these impressions that we make about another person based on, you know, appearance have profound consequences, even if those impressions are not right. There's been a ton of other work that shows a relationship between attractiveness and various life outcomes. I'm wondering if you can paint me a picture of what some of these other studies have found. What is the overall literature on the beauty by a show, Vivian?
钱。但你可以看到这如何在实验室中产生影响和冲击，所以显然你并没有真正偷走人们的钱，但你可以看到这如何在现实世界中产生影响和冲击，这可能是相当深远的。是的，我的意思是，这确实说明了我们基于外表对另一个人做出的这些印象，即使这些印象不正确，也会产生深远的后果。还有大量其他研究表明吸引力与各种生活结果之间存在关系。我想知道你是否能为我描绘一下这些其他研究发现的一些情况。关于美貌偏见的总体文献显示了什么，薇薇安？
It shows that individuals who are deemed as more attractive obtain a number of benefits. In the courtroom, they're more likely to get lighter sentences. People who are judges more attractive earn more money. In classrooms, are more likely to get attention from teachers. And so, starting from our early age, the world starts to treat attractive individuals differently than unattractive individuals and those create a self-affilling prophecy where if someone treats you as if you're a good person, as if you're a smart person, then you're more likely to meet those expectations.
它表明，被认为更有吸引力的个人获得了许多好处。在法庭上，他们更有可能获得较轻的判决。被评为更有吸引力的人赚更多的钱。在教室里，更有可能得到老师的关注。因此，从我们很小的时候起，世界就开始以不同于对待没有吸引力的个人的方式对待有吸引力的个人，这些创造了一个自我实现的预言，如果有人把你当作一个好人，一个聪明人来对待，那么你就更有可能达到这些期望。
And so these types of effects accumulate over a person's lifetime. Researchers have explored how far the beauty bias will go. One study examined how parents treat their own attractive and unattractive children. This is an observational study. And the research team basically coded for the facial attractiveness of the child and also some of the parenting behaviors, especially around safety. And one parenting behavior that they were looking at is whether the parent would buckle in the child in the shopping cart as they're going around the grocery store. And what they were reporting there was that children that had been judged to be more attractive
因此，这些类型的影响会在一个人的一生中积累。研究人员已经探索了美貌偏见会走多远。一项研究调查了父母如何对待他们自己有吸引力和没有吸引力的孩子。这是一项观察性研究。研究小组基本上对孩子的面部吸引力以及一些育儿行为进行了编码，特别是在安全方面。他们正在观察的一种育儿行为是，当父母在杂货店购物时，是否会把孩子扣在购物车里。他们报告说，那些被独立编码员判断为更有吸引力的孩子
based on the independent coders were more likely to be buckled in in the shopping cart by their parents. It suggests that even parents might be affected by this type of beauty bias when interacting with their own children. Our judgments about attractiveness are so sticky that Vivian finds people regularly go to lengths to preserve their initial impressions of others. If I think someone is attractive in other words, my behavior toward that person changes, often without my being aware of it. So this is a study done with Goul Genniden, a former graduate student and now
更有可能被父母扣在购物车里。这表明即使是父母在与自己的孩子互动时，也可能受到这种美貌偏见的影响。我们对吸引力的判断是如此根深蒂固，以至于薇薇安发现人们经常不遗余力地维护他们对他人的最初印象。换句话说，如果我认为某人有吸引力，我对那个人的行为就会改变，通常是在我没有意识到的情况下。所以这是一项与前研究生、现任教授古尔·根尼登共同完成的研究，
professor, and we had participants complete a survey and And in that survey, there were photographs of about eight women. And we asked them, do you like the person in the photograph? Would you want to hang out with the person in the photograph? How attracted are you to the person in the photograph? And these were all same sex. So women judging women. They were also asked, do you think the woman in the photograph is like an extrovert conscientious? Do you think she's agreeable? So what's called the big five personality traits? So they made personality judgments of the woman. What the volunteers in the experiment did not know is that they were looking at photos of a research assistant. Let's call her Jamie. So we have Jamie's photograph in the initial survey.
我们让参与者完成了一项调查。在那项调查中，有大约八名女性的照片。我们问他们，你喜欢照片里的人吗？你想和照片里的人一起出去玩吗？你对照片里的人有多大吸引力？这些都是同性的。所以女性评价女性。他们还被问到，你认为照片里的女性是外向、尽责的吗？你认为她随和吗？这就是所谓的“大五人格特质”？所以他们对女性做出了人格判断。实验中的志愿者不知道的是，他们正在看一名研究助理的照片。我们叫她杰米。所以我们在最初的调查中有杰米的照片。
We selected participants so that half the people liked Jamie, and that half the people did not like Jamie so much, based on the photograph. Then they came in and they all interacted with Jamie. Now Jamie didn't know how they had judged her. They're interacting with the same person, but if they initially liked her based on the photograph, they ended up liking her based on the interaction, and if they initially were kind of lukewarm about her based on the photograph, then they remained lukewarm after interacting
我们挑选参与者，使得一半的人喜欢杰米，而另一半的人基于照片不太喜欢杰米。然后他们进来，都与杰米进行了互动。杰米不知道他们是如何评价她的。他们与同一个人互动，但如果他们最初基于照片喜欢她，他们最终在互动后也会喜欢她，如果他们最初基于照片对她感觉平平，那么在与她互动后，他们仍然感觉平平。
with her. And that's really interesting to us because we separately had asked participants, do you think you can judge a person based on their photograph or do you think you would like update your impression? And in this survey, people think that they'll update their impression based on an actual conversation with someone. When you talk with someone, you get a lot more information than a photograph. You hear their voice, you see their behaviors, they tell you what they like, and so participants thought that they would certainly update.
这对我们来说非常有趣，因为我们分别问过参与者，你认为你能根据照片判断一个人吗，或者你认为你会更新你的印象吗？在那项调查中，人们认为他们会根据与某人的实际谈话来更新他们的印象。当你与某人交谈时，你获得的信息比照片多得多。你听到他们的声音，看到他们的行为，他们告诉你他们喜欢什么，所以参与者认为他们肯定会更新。
And that's not what we found at all. Some of the most remarkable work on the beauty bias has explored how our judgments about attractiveness affect not only our behavior, but the behavior of the people we observe. I asked Vivian to tell me about an experiment conducted by Mark Snyder at the University of Minnesota. So that's the classic study where he had men as participants and they were asked to have a conversation with a woman. Now the experimenter presented the men with photographs of the woman, but it wasn't the photograph of the actual woman that they were talking to. The experimenter gave them photographs of another woman, and sometimes the male participant
但这根本不是我们发现的结果。关于美貌偏见的一些最引人注目的工作探索了我们对吸引力的判断如何不仅影响我们的行为，还影响我们观察到的人的行为。我请薇薇安告诉我明尼苏达大学马克·斯奈德进行的一项实验。那是经典研究，他让男性作为参与者，要求他们与一名女性进行对话。实验者向男性展示了女性的照片，但那不是他们正在交谈的实际女性的照片。实验者给了他们另一名女性的照片，有时男性参与者
got a photograph of a track to woman, or in another condition that they got a photograph of an average looking or unattractive woman. So now some men thought that they were talking to an attractive woman and some men thought that they were talking to an unattractive woman. Because all this is happening on the phone. On the phone. And they recorded the conversation and they had independent people judge the conversation and they found that independent judges thought that the male participant who thought he was speaking to an attractive woman, they judged him to be warmer and more engaged and more interested as compared to the male participant who had thought he was
得到了一张有吸引力的女性的照片，或者在另一种情况下，他们得到了一张长相普通或没有吸引力的女性的照片。所以现在一些男人以为他们在和一个有吸引力的女人说话，一些男人以为他们在和一个没有吸引力的女人说话。因为这一切都是在电话上发生的。在电话上。他们录下了对话，并让独立人员评价对话，他们发现独立评价者认为，认为自己在与有吸引力的女性交谈的男性参与者，他们被评价为更温暖、更投入、更感兴趣，相比之下，那些认为自己在与
talking to a more average looking or unattractive woman. Notice this is similar to Vivian's finding many years later in the study featuring the research assistant she called Jamie. Men who like Jamie's photo were more engaged when they talked to Jamie in person. In the University of Minnesota study, the independent judges were asked to also judge the women in the conversations. What did the judges think of the study, the independent judges were asked to also judge the women in the conversations. What did the judges think of the women on the phone?
一个长相更普通或没有吸引力的女性交谈的男性参与者。注意，这类似于薇薇安多年后在以她称为杰米的研究助理为特色的研究中的发现。喜欢杰米照片的男性在亲自与杰米交谈时更投入。在明尼苏达大学的研究中，独立评价者也被要求评价对话中的女性。评价者对研究有什么看法，独立评价者也被要求评价对话中的女性。评价者对电话里的女性有什么看法？
What they found was that when the woman was speaking with a man who thought he was speaking to an attractive woman, she actually was judged as more attractive by the independent judges based on her voice. As compared to the woman who was speaking to the man who thought he was talking to an unattractive or average looking woman. So I mean what this is suggesting is that if I think I'm speaking to somebody attractive, regardless of whether the person actually is or isn't attractive, if I think I'm talking to someone attractive, what the study was suggesting was that I become more engaged, but even more than that, the person I'm talking with becomes more engaged and has an effect on them. And so you can see in some ways how the beauty bias has effects not just on our behavior, but on the targets of our behavior.
他们发现，当女性与一个认为自己在与有吸引力的女性交谈的男人交谈时，她实际上被独立评价者根据她的声音评价为更有吸引力。相比之下，与认为自己在与一个没有吸引力或长相普通的女性交谈的男人交谈的女性。所以我的意思是，这表明如果我认为我正在与一个有吸引力的人交谈，无论那个人实际上是否有吸引力，如果我认为我正在与一个有吸引力的人交谈，这项研究表明我变得更投入，但不仅如此，我正在交谈的人也变得更投入，并对他们产生了影响。所以你可以看出美貌偏见在某种程度上不仅对我们的行为产生影响，而且对我们行为的目标也产生影响。
Yes, and in the study where we had our participants interact with Jamie, we had a video camera in that study. And what we found was if participants like the woman, based on the photograph, now when they're interacting with her, we coded their behavior and independent coders judged the participant as warmer, more engaged, more interested. The independent coders made the same assessment of Jamie, saying she was also warmer, more engaged, and more interested.
是的，在我们让参与者与杰米互动的研究中，我们在研究中安装了一台摄像机。我们发现，如果参与者基于照片喜欢那个女人，现在当他们与她互动时，我们对他们的行为进行了编码，独立编码员评价参与者更温暖、更投入、更感兴趣。独立编码员对杰米也做出了同样的评估，说她也更温暖、更投入、更感兴趣。
And as a result, the participant leaves the conversation by saying, oh wow, we had a really great conversation, she was really engaged and warm and interested, and I really like her. And part of the reason the participant ends up liking her after the interaction is partly because of what the participant elicited from her. And so participants who based on the photograph for whatever reason, you know, were lukewarm towards her, well, they were more disengaged, less interested and less warm. Jamie in turn would then be less engaged, less interested, and less warm, with the participants who felt lukewarm toward her. These interactions created a feedback loop. And the participants themselves is saying,
结果，参与者在对话结束时说，哦哇，我们进行了一次非常棒的对话，她非常投入、温暖且感兴趣，我真的很喜欢她。参与者在互动后最终喜欢她的部分原因，部分是因为参与者从她身上引发了什么。因此，那些基于照片无论出于什么原因，你知道，对她感觉平平的参与者，嗯，他们更不投入、不感兴趣且不温暖。杰米反过来对那些对她感觉平平的参与者也会表现得不那么投入、不感兴趣且不温暖。这些互动创造了一个反馈循环。而参与者自己说，
oh, well, that person was less interested, less engaged, and less warm. I don't really like them. But part of it was what they created, what they brought into the situation. Whether we realize it or not, we all make inferences about what goes on inside of a person based on what we see on the outside. And because we're naturally drawn to what we find attractive,
哦，那个人不那么感兴趣、不那么投入、也不那么温暖。我不太喜欢他们。但部分原因是他们创造了什么，他们带入了什么情况。无论我们是否意识到，我们都会根据我们在外面看到的东西，对一个人内心发生的事情做出推断。因为我们自然会被我们认为有吸引力的东西所吸引，
there are big benefits to being beautiful. If you're good looking, chances are you have a leg up, socially, academically, even economically. But is beauty always in advantage? When we come back, when beauty backfires on us. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. There's no question about it. If you had to choose between being beautiful or not, all of us would choose to be gorgeous. There are so many advantages to being good looking, right?
长得好看有很大的好处。如果你长得好看，你很可能在社交、学术甚至经济上都占有优势。但美貌总是优势吗？当我们回来时，美貌何时会适得其反。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。毫无疑问。如果你必须在长得漂亮或不漂亮之间做出选择，我们所有人都会选择变得华丽。长得好看有很多优势，对吧？
Yes, but not always. At the University of Colorado Boulder, psychologist Stephanie Johnson has studied a paradoxical effect of beauty in the workplace. Stephanie Johnson, welcome to Hidden Brain. Hi, thanks so much for having me. Now, you found that female entrepreneurs are deemed less trustworthy when they're attractive. You have an interesting term for this. Tell me about the term and tell me about the study you conducted. interesting term for this. Tell me about the term and tell me about the study
是的，但并不总是这样。在科罗拉多大学博尔德分校，心理学家斯蒂芬妮·约翰逊研究了美貌在工作场所的一种矛盾效应。斯蒂芬妮·约翰逊，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。嗨，非常感谢邀请我。现在，你发现女性企业家在有吸引力时被认为不那么值得信赖。你对这个有一个有趣的术语。告诉我这个术语，并告诉我你进行的研究。
you conducted. Yeah, absolutely. So this was some work I did with Leah Shepard on an idea she calls the femme fatale effect. And it really builds from the narrow window in which more attractive people don't benefit. So usually more attractive people walk away with better results, but there's this small area of research that shows that at least for women being more attractive
你所做的研究。是的，绝对是。这是我和莉亚·谢泼德（Leah Shepard）合作完成的一些工作，基于她所称的“蛇蝎美人效应”（femme fatale effect）。它实际上建立在这样一个狭窄的窗口之上：即更有吸引力的人并不总是受益。通常，更有吸引力的人会获得更好的结果，但有一小部分研究表明，至少对于女性来说，更有吸引力
can have negative effects. And one of those negative effects is that people see you as less trustworthy. And if you think of, you know, the femme fatale who's able to manipulate others to get her way based on her beauty, right, this kind of Greek myth, the sirens. I guess this sticks in people's minds and so more attractive women they're seen as less trustworthy and people are more likely to want to fire them. Stephanie has run experiments where she has tried to tease out the femme fatale effect in the lab. In one study, she presented a female public relations executive who was announcing bad news at her company.
可能会产生负面影响。其中一个负面影响是人们认为你不太值得信任。如果你想到那个能够利用美貌操纵他人以达到目的的“蛇蝎美人”，对吧，这种希腊神话中的海妖塞壬。我想这在人们心中根深蒂固，所以更有吸引力的女性被认为不太值得信任，人们也更有可能想要解雇她们。斯蒂芬妮（Stephanie）进行了一些实验，试图在实验室中梳理出“蛇蝎美人效应”。在一项研究中，她展示了一位女性公关主管，她正在公司宣布坏消息。
Volunteers were shown pictures of the executive. Some were shown an attractive woman. Others were shown an unattractive woman. Volunteers were asked to imagine a scenario. It says this company has to engage in layoffs and this PR person is saying this is the reason why we're doing it do you believe her, do you trust her and what we find is the more attractive women are seen as less trustworthy. And why do you think this is happening? So in the scenario you described, the woman is essentially acting as a spokesperson for the company, and you're evaluating whether people trust what she is saying, and you're finding that the more attractive the person is, the less they trust her, and the less they trust the company.
志愿者们看到了这位主管的照片。有些人看到的是一位有吸引力的女性，另一些人看到的是一位没有吸引力的女性。志愿者们被要求想象一个场景。场景是：这家公司必须进行裁员，而这位公关人员正在说明裁员的原因。你相信她吗？你信任她吗？我们发现，更有吸引力的女性被认为不太值得信任。你认为这是为什么？在你描述的场景中，这位女性本质上是作为公司的发言人，而你正在评估人们是否信任她所说的话，你发现一个人越有吸引力，人们就越不信任她，也越不信任这家公司。
Yeah, no exactly. So why does it happen? It's a great question, because she's just the messenger, right? And you often think of messengers and spokespersons as being good looking because they're in front of the camera. I think it's the idea that when we see attractive women, you know, you want maybe you want to be around them, maybe you feel your heart rates elevated, you're more interested in talking to them, but you also feel a little bit protective because you, you know, might
是的，没错。那么为什么会发生这种情况呢？这是一个很好的问题，因为她只是个传话人，对吧？你通常会认为传话人和发言人长得好看，因为他们站在镜头前。我认为这是因为当我们看到有吸引力的女性时，你知道，你可能想和她们待在一起，也许你感到心跳加速，你更有兴趣和她们交谈，但你也会感到一点防备，因为你，你知道，可能会
fear that they can potentially manipulate you. Stephanie and her colleagues repeated the study, this time using pictures of men. As before, they asked volunteers to rate the trustworthiness of attractive and unattractive men. Yeah, no, we didn't find it for men. We looked for it, but didn't find a hymphatal effect. And again, what is your theory about why that would be the case? You know, I think it's because of this stereotype of the seductress, the woman who's going to use her feminine
担心她们可能会操纵你。斯蒂芬妮和她的同事重复了这项研究，这次使用了男性的照片。和之前一样，他们要求志愿者评估有吸引力和没有吸引力的男性的可信度。是的，我们没有在男性身上发现这种效应。我们寻找过，但没有发现“蛇蝎美人效应”。那么，关于为什么会这样，你的理论是什么？你知道，我认为这是因为“诱惑者”的刻板印象，即那个会利用她女性
wiles to manipulate and intrapen. I don't know that you have that same stereotype for the really gorgeous male, even though I would imagine that he can use his masculine whatever's to manipulate people. I don't know if there's that same character, literature, and mythology, so I don't feel like we have that stereotype as strongly as we do for women. Now, obviously when we're thinking about these situations, some of this is a lot of this is happening,
魅力来操纵和诱捕他人的女性。我不知道对于真正英俊的男性，你是否有同样的刻板印象，尽管我想象他也可以利用他的男性魅力来操纵人们。我不知道在文学和神话中是否有同样的角色，所以我感觉我们对女性的这种刻板印象并没有那么强烈。显然，当我们思考这些情况时，其中一些，很多都是在
perhaps unconsciously people are not thinking about this, but when you think about the seductress, or the template of the seductress, is this something that affects both men and women? In other words, I would do both men and women are the suspicious of good looking women? Yes, so we looked for gender differences in respondents. And I guess I didn't really think we would find
也许无意识地发生，人们并没有刻意去想，但当你想到“诱惑者”或“诱惑者”的模板时，这是影响男性和女性双方的事情吗？换句话说，男性和女性是否都对好看的女性持怀疑态度？是的，所以我们研究了受访者中的性别差异。我想我真的没想过我们会发现
the same effect for women mistrusting other women, maybe because I'm like a woman who loves women, kind of woman, but we didn't find differences in the respondents. You mean that women showed the same suspicion for good-looking women as men, did? Yes, yes. Women were just as suspicious as men. The idea that attractive women are somehow less trustworthy is an example of something called the Beauty is Beasley Effect.
女性不信任其他女性的相同效应，也许是因为我是一个喜欢女性的女性，但我们没有发现受访者之间的差异。你是说女性对好看女性表现出的怀疑和男性一样吗？是的，是的。女性和男性一样怀疑。认为有吸引力的女性不太值得信任，这是所谓的“美即是野兽效应”（Beauty is Beastly Effect）的一个例子。
Coined by a group of researchers in the 1970s and 80s, the beauty is beastly effect, is like the beauty bias in reverse. The original work was done by an outstanding researcher, Madeline Hylman, and she was looking at what is beautiful as good. That's the more attractive people tend to be more successful, love to more, get more reward seen as extroverts, intelligent, all the things. But she was finding that there was an instance in which this wasn't true and it was for women applying for managerial jobs,
由一组研究人员在20世纪70年代和80年代提出，“美即是野兽效应”就像是“美貌偏见”的反面。最初的工作是由一位杰出的研究人员玛德琳·海尔曼（Madeline Heilman）完成的，她研究的是“美即是好”。也就是说，更有吸引力的人往往更成功、更受欢迎、获得更多奖励，被视为外向、聪明等等。但她发现有一种情况并非如此，那就是女性申请管理职位时，
which this was done in the 1970s, and so, you know, at that time, managerial jobs were seen as masculine. Today, I think over 50% of managers are women, so I don't know that that would be true, but she found that more attractive women were actually seen as less competent and less suited for managerial jobs than attractive men, unattractive men, or unattractive women. And so she coined this phrase, the beauty is beastly effect. Madeline Highellman speculated the bias might come about because of the preconceptions people had about leadership and mismatches and people's minds between the kind of person who becomes a leader and the kind of person who is an attractive woman.
这是在20世纪70年代完成的，所以，你知道，在那个时候，管理职位被视为男性的工作。今天，我认为超过50%的管理者是女性，所以我不知道这是否仍然适用，但她发现更有吸引力的女性实际上被认为比有吸引力的男性、没有吸引力的男性或没有吸引力的女性能力更差，更不适合管理职位。因此，她创造了这个短语，“美即是野兽效应”。玛德琳·海尔曼推测，这种偏见可能源于人们对领导力的先入之见，以及人们心中对成为领导者的人与有吸引力的女性这类人之间的不匹配。
She phrased it as a lack of fit. So the job is masculine. Attractive women are actually by definition feminine. If you look at characteristics of what makes men and women attractive for women being more feminine, correlated with, being more attractive, it's seen as more attractive. So if I see you as feminine, you actually don't have what it takes to do this masculine job because you're too feminine for this masculine work. And it sounds silly for managerial jobs, I would say, at this point, because I actually see leaders in management as having a lot of feminine skills like you have to have empathy and be supportive. But if you were to take it to the extreme and say, like, okay, what about this gorgeous woman
她将其表述为“不匹配”（lack of fit）。所以这份工作是男性的。有吸引力的女性根据定义实际上是女性化的。如果你看看让男女具有吸引力的特征，对于女性来说，更女性化与更有吸引力相关联。所以如果我把你视为女性化，你实际上并不具备从事这份男性工作所需的素质，因为你对这份男性工作来说太女性化了。对于管理职位来说，这一点现在听起来很傻，因为我实际上认为管理层的领导者具备很多女性化的技能，比如你需要有同理心并给予支持。但如果你把它推向极端，说，好吧，如果这个漂亮的女人
comes in and applies for a job as a construction worker, and she's wearing heels and has on makeup. You're like, well, is she going to be able to lift the equipment and get all dirty and wear the work boots? That's what the lack of fit concept was. So I spoke some time ago with Marco Patecia at the University of Maryland. I believe he is now at the Singapore Management University. He ran a study looking at how good-looking men fair in the workplace. Now, he found that good-looking men were always considered more competent, regardless of profession.
进来申请建筑工人的工作，她穿着高跟鞋，化着妆。你会想，好吧，她能搬动设备，弄得浑身脏兮兮，穿上工作靴吗？这就是“不匹配”概念的含义。所以我前段时间和马里兰大学的马可·帕特西亚（Marco Patesia）谈过。我相信他现在在新加坡管理大学。他进行了一项研究，观察好看的男性在职场中的表现。他发现，无论职业如何，好看的男性总是被认为更有能力。
But then he looked at how these men were evaluated by their colleagues and he found that because of the stereotype that good-looking men are competent, these men were treated less well in workplaces that were competitive. I want to play you a short clip of what he told me. When there are these subtle hints of competition within colleagues, as is often the case, then attractive males are actually at disadvantage and they are actually discriminated against. So if you're working on a sales team and things are competitive between you and the other sales people and you mistakenly believe that a good-looking salesman is going to be a better salesman, now you might be more likely to be biased against him. So this might be an example where you know the good-looking man now actually has tougher sledding than the average looking man.
但随后他观察了这些男性如何被同事评估，他发现由于“好看的男性更有能力”这种刻板印象，这些男性在竞争激烈的职场中受到的待遇反而更差。我想给你播放一小段他告诉我的片段。当同事之间存在这种微妙的竞争暗示时，通常情况下，有吸引力的男性实际上处于劣势，他们实际上受到了歧视。所以如果你在一个销售团队工作，而你和其他销售人员之间存在竞争，并且你错误地认为一个好看的销售员会是一个更好的销售员，那么你现在可能更有可能对他产生偏见。所以这可能是一个例子，你知道，好看的男性现在实际上比长相普通的男性面临更艰难的处境。
That's right. So I loved that study because to me, I couldn't believe they found a beauty as beastly bias for men. But when you read it, the study and the nuance, it's that the people making the decisions would be indirect competition with Batman, which isn't often the case for people you hire, but with that study showed is people are self-interested. And if I know that I'm going to bring someone onto the team that can outcompete me because they're better looking and they're more competent, then I might be less likely to give them a chance. But isn't it the case that this is not just about hiring? So to go back to the sales example that we talked about, let's say you have a car dealership and you have like 20 sales people,
没错。所以我很喜欢那项研究，因为对我来说，我不敢相信他们发现了针对男性的“美即是野兽”偏见。但当你阅读它，研究和其中的细微差别时，你会发现做出决定的人会与那个男人存在直接竞争，这在招聘时并不常见，但那项研究表明人们是自私的。如果我知道我要把一个能胜过我的人招进团队，因为他们长得更好看、能力更强，那么我可能就不太愿意给他们机会。但这不是不仅仅关于招聘吗？回到我们谈到的销售例子，假设你有一家汽车经销商，你有20名销售人员，
and you have three very good looking salesmen on this on this team, I think what the Petitia study is suggesting is that these men might actually have a tougher go of it among their colleagues because their colleagues see them as more threatening because of the association between being good looking and competent and therefore a threat. No, absolutely. You see this on sales teams all the time that a potential client or customer comes in and do I call the person who I'm trying to refer them to or do I try to steal the customer because it's one of those tough things that
而这个团队里有三名非常好看的男销售员，我认为帕特西亚的研究表明，这些男性在同事中可能实际上处境更艰难，因为他们的同事因为“好看”与“有能力”之间的联系，从而将他们视为威胁。不，绝对是。你在销售团队中经常看到这种情况，潜在的客户进来了，我是该把客户推荐给我试图推荐的人，还是我该试图抢走这个客户？因为这是那些棘手的事情之一，
like I can work really hard, I can stay extra hours, I can try to get ahead but I can't really, it's pretty hard to change my appearance. And so it becomes like a real competitive advantage for people that might threaten others in the organization. I mean, it's an interesting idea because I think both with the case of good-looking women and good-looking men, I think our stereotype as a general rule is that these people always have it good. They always have it easy.
比如我可以非常努力地工作，我可以加班，我可以尝试领先，但我真的无法，改变我的外表是相当困难的。因此，这对于组织中可能威胁到他人的其他人来说，变成了一种真正的竞争优势。我的意思是，这是一个有趣的想法，因为我认为无论是好看的女性还是好看的男性，我认为我们作为一般规则的刻板印象是，这些人总是过得很好。他们总是过得很轻松。
And I think what this research is suggesting is that at least in some limited circumstances, they actually might not. Yeah, I think that's a good summary of at least what my research shows and I find that more attractive women are more likely to experience sexual harassment and doubts of competence and all these other things. And so I'm very sensitive to that. I think these are important findings. And if you just look at the overall data at the end of the day, as you started our conversation, we would all be better off being beautiful. That is the strongest effect, even though there's instances where people might not trust you, think they feel more competitive toward you. Your salary is still higher, and particularly for men compared to women for being more attractive.
而我认为这项研究表明，至少在某些有限的情况下，他们实际上可能并非如此。是的，我认为这是对我的研究至少所显示内容的很好总结，我发现更有吸引力的女性更有可能经历性骚扰和能力质疑以及所有其他事情。所以我对此非常敏感。我认为这些是重要的发现。如果你只看最终的整体数据，正如我们开始谈话时所说，我们所有人如果长得漂亮都会过得更好。这是最强的影响，尽管在某些情况下人们可能不信任你，认为他们对你感到更有竞争意识。你的薪水仍然更高，特别是对于男性而言，相比女性，因为更有吸引力。
Stephanie has found that one way to mitigate the negative effects of beauty in the workplace is to bring the bias to the surface, to make people aware of the bias. In one study, she had volunteers evaluate beautiful candidates for a job where the candidates expressly put the issue of their attractiveness on the table. And they say, I realize I don't look like your typical construction worker. Or I realize there aren't a lot of women in construction. And then it's followed with, but if you look at my resume, you'll see I have a lot of experience in this area and I'm very competent as what it says.
斯蒂芬妮发现，减轻美貌在职场中负面影响的一种方法是将偏见浮出水面，让人们意识到这种偏见。在一项研究中，她让志愿者评估一份工作的漂亮候选人，候选人明确地把他们外貌的问题摆在了桌面上。他们说，我意识到我看起来不像你们典型的建筑工人。或者我意识到建筑行业里没有很多女性。然后接着说，但如果你看我的简历，你会发现我在这个领域有很多经验，而且正如上面所说，我非常有能力。
In the other condition, the control condition, they don't acknowledge their appearance or their gender. They just say, if you look at my resume, you'll realize I have a lot of experience and I'm very competent. And we found less bias against attractive women when they acknowledged the fact that they were different. And I, you know, what is this mean? It's like, I think people are focusing on the fact that this person doesn't fit in. They're not really listening to what they're saying. They're just like, this is, what is she doing here?
在另一种情况下，即对照组，他们不承认自己的外貌或性别。他们只是说，如果你看我的简历，你会意识到我有很多经验，而且我非常有能力。我们发现，当有吸引力的女性承认她们与众不同这一事实时，针对她们的偏见减少了。我，你知道，这意味着什么？就像，我认为人们关注的是这个人不适合的事实。他们并没有真正听她在说什么。他们只是觉得，这是，她在做什么？
And when you acknowledge it, you kind of like pop them out of their bubble and then of course they say, oh no, I wasn't thinking that at all. And then they start paying attention to what you're saying. Right. So in other words, calling attention to the bias and basically saying, you know, it may appear that I'm not a good fit. It allows people in some ways to maybe stop thinking about this unconsciously and start
当你承认这一点时，你就像把他们从泡沫中弹出来，然后当然他们会说，哦不，我根本没那么想。然后他们就开始关注你在说什么了。对。所以换句话说，引起对偏见的注意，基本上说，你知道，我看起来可能不太合适。这在某种程度上让人们也许停止无意识地思考这个问题，并开始
thinking about it consciously and say, oh yeah, you know, in fact, I did think that you were not a good fit. Thanks for flagging that. And now maybe I'll actually give you a serious second look. I think so. Yeah, I mean, I feel like you have to tread carefully, because I can't imagine going into that. So, you know, my interview and saying, listen, I know I'm so beautiful and like, and that's weird. Because then there's like a whole other list of problems they might have with like this person's a narcissist and not very beautiful. So probably insane. And yeah. So I think there's caveats, you know, we tried to say, I know I don't look like your typical construction worker. I realize I'm
有意识地思考它，并说，哦是的，你知道，事实上，我确实认为你不合适。谢谢你指出这一点。现在也许我会真正给你一个认真的重新审视。我想是这样。是的，我的意思是，我觉得你必须小心行事，因为我无法想象走进那个。所以，你知道，我的面试，然后说，听着，我知道我太漂亮了，而且，这很奇怪。因为那样的话，他们可能会对这个人有另一长串的问题，比如这个人是个自恋者，而且不是特别漂亮。所以可能疯了。是的。所以我认为有注意事项，你知道，我们试着说，我知道我看起来不像你们典型的建筑工人。我意识到我
probably younger than many people in your organization. But I started working, you know, I have 10 years of work experience, even at this young age. So one of the complicated things about the beauty bias is that unlike biases like racism or sexism where we would say, you know, it's wrong in every circumstance and every situation, there are many domains where we all enthusiastically endorse the importance of beauty. So no one would find it problematic if you said that you like to movie star because of how he looks so that you admire a fashion model because she's gorgeous. And of course in our personal lives, recognizing and complementing one another and how we look is routine in many relationships and almost something of a requirement in romantic relationships. I'm wondering if this complicates the fight against the beauty bias, the fact that we heartily endorse the bias. In fact, we don't even think of it as a bias in many domains of our lives.
可能比你们组织中的许多人年轻。但我开始工作，你知道，即使在这么年轻的时候，我也已经有10年的工作经验了。所以关于美貌偏见，复杂的事情之一是，与种族主义或性别歧视等偏见不同，我们可能会说，你知道，它在任何情况下和任何处境下都是错误的，但在许多领域，我们所有人都热情地认可美貌的重要性。所以如果有人说你喜欢电影明星是因为他的长相，或者你钦佩时装模特是因为她很漂亮，没有人会觉得这有问题。当然，在我们的个人生活中，认可和赞美彼此的长相在许多关系中是例行公事，在浪漫关系中几乎是一种要求。我想知道这是否使对抗美貌偏见的斗争变得复杂，即我们衷心认可这种偏见的事实。事实上，在我们生活的许多领域，我们甚至不认为这是一种偏见。
Does that make it harder to actually fight it in other domains? I think it makes it impossible to fight it in other domains. You know, I think psychologically, I would say it's not possible to get rid of it. In my head, in my mind, I unconsciously will make eye contact longer with people who are better looking. Like, study show this. I can try not to, if I see a good looking person, I can be like, oh, and let me not look at them. But realistically, if I'm not, you know, today I'll probably be good, but tomorrow I probably will not. So I don't think we as humans can overcome the bias.
这是否使在其他领域真正对抗它变得更难了？我认为这使得在其他领域对抗它变得不可能。你知道，我认为从心理学上讲，我想说摆脱它是不可行的。在我的脑海里，在我的思想中，我会无意识地与长得更好看的人进行更长时间的眼神交流。就像，研究显示了这一点。我可以试着不这样做，如果我看到一个好看的人，我可以想，哦，让我不要看他们。但现实中，如果我不是，你知道，今天我可能会做得很好，但明天我可能就不会了。所以我认为我们作为人类无法克服这种偏见。
So I think instead you have to have systems and structures in place, like at least in a hiring context or workplace context, in a dating context, you know, you do you. But when it comes to hiring and making good business decisions, finding ways to evaluate people that are not subject to the bias of appearance. Stephanie Johnson is a psychologist at the University of Colorado Boulder. She's also the author of Inclusify, the power of uniqueness and belonging to build innovative teams.
所以我认为相反，你必须有系统和结构到位，至少在招聘环境或职场环境中，在约会环境中，你知道，你做你自己。但当涉及到招聘和做出好的商业决策时，找到评估人们的方法，这些方法不受外貌偏见的影响。斯蒂芬妮·约翰逊（Stephanie Johnson）是科罗拉多大学博尔德分校的心理学家。她也是《Inclusify: The Power of Uniqueness and Belonging to Build Innovative Teams》一书的作者。
Stephanie, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you enjoy the show and would like to support our work, please consider becoming a member of our podcast subscription Hidden Brain Plus. That's where you'll find exclusive episodes you
斯蒂芬妮，非常感谢你今天参加《Hidden Brain》节目。非常感谢邀请我。Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、安妮·墨菲·保罗（Annie Murphy Paul）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）和尼克·伍德伯里（Nick Woodbury）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行编辑。如果你喜欢这个节目并想支持我们的工作，请考虑成为我们播客订阅Hidden Brain Plus的会员。在那里你会找到独家剧集，你
won't hear anywhere else. To become a member of Hidden Brain Plus, find Hidden Brain in the Apple Podcasts app and then click the Try Free button for a 7-day try. Or you can sign up at apple.co slash hidden brain. I'm Shankar Vedanthantham. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在其他任何地方都听不到。要成为Hidden Brain Plus的会员，请在Apple Podcasts应用程序中找到Hidden Brain，然后点击“免费试用”按钮进行7天试用。或者你可以在apple.co/hiddenbrain注册。我是尚卡尔·维丹坦（Shankar Vedantam）。很快再见。你 目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。